we got to remind you May 10th the first
ever it's an event first ever live taste
buds live streaming we've been selling
tickets to that you can get an exclusive
link and watch the premiere of this live
streaming also going to be here in New
York City in front of a live audience
surprises all sorts of different things
happening all sorts of crazy battles
gonna happen surprises from every angle
stay tuned for all the information and
we got live dates of our own yes
what's up guys come see me on the road
right now go to savocanocomedy.com for
tickets uh April 7th I'm in Seattle with
the guys at the climate pledge Arena
April 8th at the Keller Auditorium in
Portland we have two shows the second
one still has tickets uh Bangor Maine on
April 27th the Wang theater in Boston
three shows April 28th and 29th that
weekend uh two shows are sold out so
there's one show left to get tickets
then we go Maverick Center in Utah May
5th Bellco Theater in Denver May 6th uh
let's see what else here then we go into
Texas we're going to uh Arlington Austin
at the Moody Center in Sugarland Texas
at the Smart Financial Center May 19 20
and 21 and just to round out this summer
right now these are the last dates I
have before the new dates are announced
there's gonna be a lot of new dates
announced soon so if you don't hear it
just check back but we got Columbus on
June 2nd Cleveland on June 3rd at the
rocket mortgage field house and the
Schottenstein Center respectively two
huge venues there the Fox Theater in
Detroit on June 4th June 15th we're in
Minneapolis uh June 16th Des Moines at
Wells Fargo Arena June 17th the T-Mobile
Center in Kansas City and the last dates
right now before we announce new who won
no one's Nashville Grand Ole Opry July
27th uh Cambridge Field House in
Indianapolis on the 28th and St Louis we
got two in St Louis on the 29th at the
stifle theater and one there's tickets
available so hope to see you on the road
Impractical Jokers every Thursday nights
at 10 brand new episodes right now on
TBS and true and please go to our store
check out our merch we're about to sell
out of this and we're about to launch
new ones so this is the last chance to
get some merch I'll see you guys on the
road Joe DeRosa here folks I got live
dates coming up this Thursday April 6th
I'll be in Stamford Connecticut at New
York comedy club April 20th Cleveland
Ohio at dunlap's Corner Bar two shows
that night uh you sold out the first one
we added a second and I think the second
one is almost sold out too April 21st
and 22nd Columbus Ohio at the attic
Comedy Club we're doing four shows there
Baltimore Maryland on April 28th and
29th at the Port Comedy Club four shows
uh and then May 3rd New York New York
crane theater the I Never Promised You a
Rose Garden residency that might be the
last time we do this in New York uh so I
don't know yet but anyway come out to
that show come out to all the shows
jodarosainfo.com for all show
information and tickets and of course if
you're in New York come to Joey Rose's
open seven days a week 11 30 a.m every
day food
drinks fun it's a great time
joeyrosesnyc.com
[Music]
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds hey everybody it's time for
t-a-s-t-e butts
with me today is my co-host Joe DeRosa
who's in the middle of chewing on a
turkey sandwich and I just wanted to get
going
uh today's battle
today's battle is going to be hummus am
I saying that right hummus oh hummus but
isn't the like what's the the original
dialect of hummus you look like the
original man I don't know you're you're
Egyptian is that do you does that mean
something uh hummus is uh like you guys
how much is how much is a tricky bird
because it's it's it's I don't know
which culture can really claim it it's
Middle Eastern but it's also Israeli
yeah I think that's that's it mostly
right it's Mediterranean there you go
that's probably the word right would
that also be Greek then would it yeah is
it big in Greek cuisine
garbanzo beans babe garbanzo bean is a
chickpea did you know that I didn't know
that that's what they are it's
synonymous sure the toasted chickpea did
it this week
nice really yeah oh God what are you
getting out of that what's going on a
nice crunch you put it in salads it's a
nice thing to put in soup it's a
different texture I have had a crunchy
chickpea yeah I mean they they sell them
you know like as snacks already but you
can toast them at home yeah see I I got
those shits at the airport actually all
right
but I did it at home she she fried them
up at home not fried them no just
toasted them on the pan yeah
um but anyway so we're doing hummus
versus onion dip French onion dip
which is what does it matter if it's
French or not
it's usually called french onion dip I
put onion dip in there is it not
or am I just thinking of french onion
soup no no it could be called french
onion dip but I think onion dip is well
I think you know we're growing Regional
with hummus I think you should you
should clean no but here it is though
French onion dip is typically made with
french onion soup mix a mixture of dried
onions and beef bouillon onion dip is
made with onions okay well I I I'm gonna
let you take it in my head did the same
thing sure so on the on the post on
Twitter guys a lot of sometimes people
still ask hey how do we vote
go to my go to my Twitter which is Sal
vulcano and we post the polls and then
you can vote there and then we we talk
about your results here yeah onion
Dippers maybe transferring polls to
YouTube or IG soon when the Twitter
Lords uh take away polls from regular
people and you gotta pay to get a blue
check mark and only people have blue
check marks can vote and I don't know if
I want to pay for a blue check mark and
then also how many people are going to
be voting so wait so they're going to
take away all blue check marks unless
you pay for it maybe yeah everyone's
getting d uh verified and then you have
to pay for verification again which is
so stupid because then there's really no
real verification right because now I'm
not verified because they took it away
and then if I buy it anyone could buy it
so they're verifying that the Bots
aren't breathing people with pulses and
IDs and stuff that's what they're trying
to find yeah but they don't need to do
that to people who are already verified
it's all people who are already verified
are verified it's all done so the bot
excuse doesn't doesn't hold water
um you guys want to take a guess at the
largest serving of hummus ever
you mean like packaged or manufactured
or like someone who's someone ate it it
just says it was made in Lebanon and
weighed over 23 000 pounds
what'd they do with that it had to be
for an event of some kind
um so that's going to be our battle
today by the way yeah the difference
between French onion dip and onion dip
is like the difference between champagne
and Prosecco okay it's like you know
what I mean sure so I'm taking one as
the same all right but but
oh my God that's gross
so just like Outdoors exposed to the
elements there's so much surface area on
that it's gross it's there's something
gross about that it's like it literally
is it has it what does that have a
diameter of what I mean that's probably
like a 25 foot diameter no it says it
weighs more than four tons there's a
gastronomic scroll up pimp there's a
gastronomic war with Israel Over
Regional over the regional delicacy
uh the wars played out publicly for
years two sides out doing each other for
title the world's best and world's
largest hummus dish no need to call that
a war but there's enough going on over
there I know I know it's really doesn't
need to be the war on hummus as well
there's a rivalry
yeah exactly
um look look hummus came into my life
very late hummus came into my life first
time I've had hummus do you want to get
into this I thought we're going to talk
about the live show first live show you
wanted it you've asked us for two
straight years you're a little adhds a
little do you you know how much
medication I'm on and that's I'm still
breaking through the medication for you
to tell me do I have it and I'm on like
multiple high-level doses of medication
well we just said a thing I started a
new message I'm gonna start a new
medication tonight
God bless you I'm looking to solve yeah
yeah I know I get it and nothing's
working we were just down the hall in
the little kitchen area yeah Simmy was
sitting out there yeah so we can't stand
your bits yeah the great shimmy
Simmy you guys you were walking we're at
the offices you were talking to Sammy
walking into the kitchen area he was
sitting just on the couch facing it yeah
you and Timmy finished the sentence in
that break I said Sal we should really
start because our guest for the next
episode is coming in you said absolutely
let's do it and I knew in the two
seconds that followed you would forget
that that happened and sure enough seven
minutes later I was sitting here going
where is South to be fair when I came in
you were balls deep and I'm a turkey
sandwich
uh
uh uh the live show an event not to be
missed we are all going at this full-on
and we just decided today it's it's
going to be a live streaming ticketed
event on May 10th so everyone all over
the world or at least where this service
is allowed can watch it we decided today
we're also gonna make it live here in
New York City in front of an audience as
well
um the date is May 10th it's a Wednesday
Wednesday May 10th tickets for streaming
uh will be on sale probably this uh
within the next week or two
um we will announce it we'll announce it
on all socials we'll announce it on the
podcast uh and then tickets for the live
event probably right right there for the
live studio audience will be right there
as well yes it's going to be a super
sized episode it's going to be taste
buds like you've never seen it before
yes we have guests lined up big big
guests surprises we have other surprises
lined up that you do not want to miss
this is going to be the premiere of this
episode this thrive episode will speak
to the entire taste buds mythology so
far absolutely and you will be able to
and it'll be on uh live streaming that
night and then available on demand for a
week after that so anybody who buys that
ticket is going to see it live before
anyone else you'll have that whole week
to see it it'll you know and and and and
and honestly dude the stuff that we were
talking about today and and all the
ideas that we have that we're gonna
throw at this and all the surprises and
all the fun stuff it is going to be a
[__] show fun party I mean it's gonna be
great we don't want to miss it if you're
a taste buds fan uh and you've been
waiting for this live episode where it's
a double whammy people wanted to see us
live you get to do that people wanted to
vote live and hear us argue in real time
you're gonna see that and there's going
to be tons of surprises uh it won't be
in the studio it's gonna be in like an
actual venue here uh I can't I mean
we're so excited about it yes details to
come with when tickets go we promise you
this this is going to be
worth it this is going to be you this is
going to be a you you can't miss this I
love the sales you're putting on this
because I know what this is going to be
like this is going to be and and I'm
going to want to listen nice to hear
when we do when I do when I do an event
it's just like when I used to bartend
throw theme parties I don't leave any
stone unturned now I have a question
we're gonna have fun with the live
studio audience we're gonna have
surprises for you there's gonna be
participatory things going on the people
at home will probably set up some kind
of live polling yeah right we're gonna
do some live ball which we could do and
what about uh it's all gone all right
all right ready
pimp were you gonna say something not at
all no
uh inside jokes from the no press crew
is you don't like it something was just
edited out and uh uh pimp what's up you
were gonna say something new ice cream
in the world for you yes we plugged this
event enough right yeah
we plug the event if you live in Oshkosh
you're never going to see this live if
you live in Canada you're probably not
going to see us like this is your only
way to actually see this the thing is
since we started day one day one
messages came in
I want to I want to vote live I want the
polling to be live and what's
interesting about this is after 120
episodes Plus
this event will be the very first time
that there will be live statistical up
to the second voting which means that
the strength of our arguments
could sway people in real time now by
Nature when people vote on Twitter by
Nature It's usually the week before this
show comes out we do not look at the
results we battle for who we think is
going to win and then we see the results
but
thus those votes those polls are taken
just by people's strict opinion of what
they feel this will be the first time
which people have asked since episode
one to vote and also take into
consideration our points and
counterpoints in our argument right so
you will see the voting shifting as we
do this
I think uh I think that's an interesting
thing you've brought up and I didn't
think of that until right now yeah until
you just said it and put it in my head
as well as and we don't want to give
away we're going to be giving away
little pieces of information weekly
leading up to it by right now it's in
about a month like you're gonna tease
you're gonna tease what do you want do
you want to tell them what's happening
no no I'm saying you should tease them
no we no okay you don't puke it all out
at once who the hell taught you how to
Market well I didn't puke anything out
yet all right there's been no deed
except the date foreplay babe okay so
for first things first we don't know if
we're going to announce the battle
the battle is a Powerhouse battle we
will announce it that night
yes yeah just like we did with this the
poll goes up we know we think we we
we're pretty sure we know what the
battle is going to be and it's going to
be it's going to be the heavyweight bout
of the century the Thriller in Manila
yes all that all the whatever you want
we already name the battle we should you
know we should do the marketing should
be like those old boxing photos uh those
old boxing promos you know like those
old school like Southern like a boxing
when there was big matches that old
school
um type of you know what I'm talking
about yes oh well you just stared at me
like you were having something on my
face I'm listening to you okay I didn't
think you needed verbal confirmation
that I knew what a boxing match rename
it yes
I understand yes I think it's a good
idea terrific thank you so much
I can even see the foods with boxing
gloves on in the old school photo yes
and it's it's not gonna be the Thriller
in Manila but we'll figure out what it's
going to be with you all right so it's
not going to be the throne vanilla
yeah but that's that's going to be I
don't think this is truly you know what
the battle is going to be do you say yes
I do do you think and this is so does
that finger evidently he's
doing a lot of this yeah so these are
this is can't lose versus can't lose do
you have don't make any hints to what it
is but do you even have an idea of who
would win that battle
no it's insane no no it's no idea a
million dollars what he what even the
percentages it's a tough one it's a
tough one it's it's that's it's it's
it's such it's such a good battle that
I'm like
I'm like I don't know what we like when
we do a second which I'm sure we will
eventually do a second live show stream
you know I'm like I wouldn't even
following yeah maybe if it's a close
match it's a rematch there's a rematch
clause in this one that's how big a deal
it is you know I will say though I would
like to distribute these items out as
well that's gonna be fun that would be
interesting that's doable that's doable
that would be very interesting that is
doable that is doing right everybody
that's actually of that it let's not
let's not talk about anymore because I
mean I feel like the more we tint it uh
this is the foreplay it might start but
it might start giving away people are
going to start guessing I don't want
anybody yes you can't guess
you're going to get to taste the items
that we're battling can't guess that's a
good point all right okay I don't know
that's another thing people always say
to us I wish you'd have it right there I
wish you'd eat it real time I wish we
could taste it real time that's
happening they don't like when we eat in
real time no they do I don't another oh
they've complained they say stop chewing
on the mics it's disgusting all I heard
is please eat the food real time and we
said yeah that's this isn't
I wish I had hummus on this oh you put
hummus on a sandwich why wouldn't I no
not for me what's your problem before we
move on
when do we want to tease
the amazing thing that's happening
in regards to to you
not yet okay
when do we want to talk about the crazy
guests we're having
not yet okay
not yet
okay especially since I can't remember
who the ghost okay no you know you know
I just I'll you'll you'll look in the
text also live entertainment
I'm I'm saying it because I'm making it
happen trust me
oh it's gonna run the it's gonna run the
gamut what's so live enter what do you
mean by that where's the library no no
we're going to have this you don't even
know
there's going to be all sorts of live
entertainment okay I'm telling you I'm
making this happen what do you mean by
all sorts well how do I you don't want
me to say anything and then you're
asking me direct questions it seems like
you just took the live show and made
some huge decisions that I'm not aware
of I did
and I don't understand what you're
saying you want to whisper to you well
pimp could just mute
it forbid though God forbid
[Music]
put your mic down and cover your face
why would we do that
but it has nothing
at the show
one of those suggestions was very good
what I'm getting at what I'm getting at
is this will be a spectacle May 10th
taste buds live maybe a spectacle
put your money on that's that's how
we'll advertising
wow
what is was that a classical uh that's
that was the Meow Mix song but we're not
here to talk about Meow Mix we're here
to talk about Noom guys Noom uses
psychology not Trends to help you make
uh sustainable choices in the way that
you eat food your relationship with food
to achieve your weight loss goals yes
this is something totally different it's
not a fad diet anything like that it's a
lifestyle a Noom is I think the only the
only people I know doing this type of
thing I think it's great and as a guy
that struggles with his diet and
fluctuates up and down in weight as you
all let me know every week in the
comment section thank you very much for
that uh I can say that I appreciate what
noon does Noom helped me redefine the
way I looked at food not just from a
psychological standpoint which is
amazing and that aspect of it is truly
truly unique but they also get into the
science of it and why certain things uh
fill you up in a certain way why certain
foods are smarter than other things and
and not obvious stuff uh that you
already know it's great this is
psychology based the entire entire
approach is psychology-based it empowers
you to build a more sustainable set of
habits and behaviors when it comes to
your diet sure whatever your health
goals are the flexible program focuses
on progress instead of perfection choose
your own level of support from five
minute daily check-ins to personal
coaching stop chasing Health Trends and
build sustainable healthy habits with
new psychology based approach start your
trial today at noon.com tastebud that's
singular
n-o-oom.com tastebud to sign up today
for your trial check out also new noom's
first ever book the new mindset a deep
dive into the psychology of behavior
change available now wherever your books
are sold folks we're here to talk to you
about bespoke post one of our most
awesome days of the month is when our
bespoke box of awesome I love it because
I always forget it's coming and then it
comes and it's literally a gift for me
that like someone else that they choose
they curated and I'm pulling wild stuff
out dude I got everything I got I got
like like I got duffel bags I got suit
luggage I got knives I got a a fresh
mozzarella making kit babe I got a
chef's knife unbelievable he sent me a
chef's knife a beautiful chef's knife
and a uh one of the little is that a
paring knife one of the little ones yeah
absolutely oh my God these are gorgeous
I was about I'm not kidding I was in the
market for a chef's night because I
needed it and they know
yeah it's nuts bespoke post box of
awesome to get started you're gonna take
a quiz at bespoke I'm sorry you're gonna
take a quiz at boxofawesome.com and then
you're gonna give them answers and
that's going to help them pick the right
box of awesome for you they release new
boxes every every month across a ton of
different categories
each box is valued around 70 bucks which
is great but you're only going to pay a
fraction of that price plus with each
box of awesome you're supporting small
businesses that's important that's what
I really like 90 of everything that
comes in your box of awesome is from a
small up and coming brand as a small
business owner I can't tell you how cool
that is at a company working on this
scale is doing that it's free to sign up
you can skip a month you can cancel any
time I'm telling you people you got
nothing to lose here some of the boxes
are uh there's the Terra I got the
Weekender which is yeah go ahead sorry
no I got the Weekender which is like the
leather weekend bag I got the Damascus
steel knife which was the forge yes um
this week I got I also have the week I
got bath like like really high like nice
bath bombs essential oils and stuff like
that this was my last box and I made
fresh mozzarella with the kit oh I have
my kitchen tomato unfortunately it's so
cool yeah it's cool stuff like that and
actually like I did it with you know I
did it with my niece and like it gave me
a family memory so this is not just
stuff like it's fun get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up a box
of awesome.com and enter the code
tastebuds at checkout that's
boxofawesome.com code taste buds for 20
off your first box box of awesome.com
code taste buds
now we're talking right now all right
Jesus Christ all right sorry to be
enthusiastic I love how enthusiastic you
are you just you just yelled an
exasperation
you said Jesus Christ well that's just
how I am all right we know we know uh
that's just how I am I feeling I'm being
a little bossy today I apologize I'll
accept it thank you not to them just to
you right Paul sustain the uh
I'm kidding I wasn't bossy to be I feel
I was a little bossy to pimp Pippa I
don't care I like it man go for it
that's you agreeing I was bossy
no you're like boss baby I'm just being
uh open to you being bossy that's fine I
don't want to be bossy why not it's
almost boost yourself I do think I'm a
hashtag boss [__] I've said it for
years I said it before it was hashtag
yeah
yeah like a boss [__]
um okay so the live event is happening
and then pimp you have a thing about
McDonald's that is also going to tease
sort of ties into what our next episode
will be our next episode after today is
strawberry milk versus chocolate milk
that's next week uh today uh is not that
battle but pimp has a very interesting
story that sort of ties into that battle
or at least teases it a bit McDonald's
drops a new Strawberry Shortcake
McFlurry
it's okay it's just that McDonald's got
brought up
I well I didn't bring it up this looks
really quick on the goddamn phone
because we should be getting a share
even even a half percent that's why
you'll be impressive did I tell you this
right when I say there's a part in my
stand-up show where I reference
McDonald's and it's not like a bit about
McDonald's here
really people cheer at that part and at
the end at well yeah towards the end of
the show I mentioned
salsa windfall and they cheer at that
too I love it it's wild do we do salsa
versus sour cream we did yes we
definitely did salsa versus guac I
didn't see it okay
um the that can you scroll back I will
try that uh strawberry short it looks so
good you know why it looks good it looks
like remember the chocolate eclair pops
yeah of course so good right strawberry
shortcake strawberry short chocolate
eclair toasted almond pimp you're
killing me here I'm trying to read the
to read the McDonald's story oh he just
Googled chocolate clear about to the
Strawberry Shortcake
No it didn't hold on I'm saying he had
this open
it's a mixture of bossy and just just
being in character for the show now how
many
no no I'm just trying to figure out
where you're going pimp does have it in
my defense pimp in my defense and back
me up on this pimp does have a tendency
when you're mid-reading in the middle of
a sentence to go to a different page or
scroll down for what you're reading
where are you gonna go wait wait wait
but he is also yes but it's also like
it's just bad I think if you're on that
end of it and we're talking live just
back me yes back me thank you I was I
was playing Devils out I was playing
on his end it might be hard because we
we we're switching topics so fast and
also it might be hard because you click
off the page
he went right to it huh you said it he
went right too I know I feel that that
is less uh I think that's a little less
him being thorough and a little more of
a symptom of some sort of attention
disorder that he might have he heard the
phrase chocolate eclair disorder I said
chocolate eclair pop and he just had to
start typing it and searching for it
that AI is rotten your brain to turn in
your mind gosh you think that was on
point what he did I think it was laser
focused because I'm serious right now
I'm joking with the pimp well I'm just
having the same conversation you are
laugh audibly please so they know we're
kidding around I love you Joe I love you
he's laughing silently over there like a
muppet can you fake alive
that's not come out of your mouth
um remember
in the early years when pimp wouldn't
speak at all
at the very beginning we started just we
had to pull him in but he wouldn't talk
or anything and he was always like
remember in the beginning some people
were like hate is gonna hate all the
time but remember people were like who's
the [__] guy laughing the laugh is
annoying me and now they're like I got
pimps left tattooed on me yeah yeah I
know I know
um now we need to share a story about V
the good humans he's left out now we
love these
V is the
the characters all right
[Laughter]
um I will tell you this earlier I made
pimp cut a thing he said out of the show
and ever since I've been haunted that I
shouted like an [__] you didn't see
it people so you don't know what I'm
talking about because it's cut out
already here's what it was
kidding I'm kidding and then you did a
thing where I said can we please just
not and you went like this fine and I
was like oh I feel like I I couldn't I
like hit an annoying thing with Sally
got annoyed no ultimately I can't change
the way you feel and your feelings are
real and so that's what's most important
thank you I love you so much when you
talk to me like that I love you yeah so
it doesn't happen enough
face
you are the you're the [__] guy with
the cloud the guy from peanuts yeah who
are you with the cloud Pig Pen no
pikminish Linus is the one but Charlie
Brown also is everything goes wrong wait
Linus plays the piano
miners don't have the cloud on top of
them does he Charlie Brown is actually
like bad luck nothing goes yeah yeah
yeah
he walks around he always has a rain
cloud over what's that does that make
you the girl at the football face
Charlie Brown Lucy yeah yeah her name
was Lucy but they all call the loose
what's that from
uh give me another hint
it is oh I thought he had like like dirt
around them there's a guy with a cloud
or like a rain cloud that's not a
character I feel like they just really
it's Charlie Brown oh wait tell him give
me another hint on that uh the next line
that rhymes with is 40 Deuce which
should give it away wait yeah it was
what they are called a loose
[Music]
with bottle in hand the microphone stand
hey yo homeboy what you doing
uh all right
um the the McFlurry wait back to the
McFlurry the McFlurry looks so good
because that do you see what they did
they took that wonderful sponge front no
it that's all the crunchy stuff that's
on the outside of that pop and they
mixed it in with ice cream that's the
magic
oh my God that looks good dude I'm sorry
the strawberry ice cream looks good to
you I like strawberry ice cream yeah
okay when you when it melts a little bit
the strawberry ice cream
it has a it's almost like the cousin of
strawberry milk right
yeah I'm strawberry milk and I'm
chocolate milk so I'm just noting what
you're saying here yeah you can note it
to death okay it's gonna change it for
those good humor pops the three big ones
the big guns what toasted almond
chocolate eclair Strawberry Shortcake
take a walk toast it out I disagree
never even had it are you nuts never
even seen it oh dude you're you're
you're you're out of pocket on that I'll
give you the good humor everyone we
should do it can we list this as a
triple battle for those three Good Humor
bars the chocolate eclair the toast and
I'm in the strawberry short I'll give
you the good good humor Trifecta good
tell me it because you're way off here
chocolate eclair
no no the chocolate eclair
what are you shaking your head at but
you tell me which you're ranking yeah
yeah why'd you go like this because I
don't agree chocolate number one oh I'm
saying the trifecta okay the three yeah
but I'm saying in any order whatever
you're saying that you say the three are
those no no but I'm saying they're this
they're the three bars like they're the
three bars those are the three flavors
but if you want to talk three Good Humor
powerhouses oh okay just ready not
including them no I'm including two of
these I don't hear what I'm saying
they're saying this yeah yeah yeah the
three Good Humor the Holy Trinity of
Good Humor pops that's new that's
Reese's and yeah that's new are these
it's the chocolate eclair right
you wouldn't argue that that's one of
their Titan pops
sure sure sure Strawberry Shortcake okay
right yeah
rocket pop is number three it is the ice
it is not the toaster the red blue and
white ice yes dude that is like a
legendary popsicle is that good humor I
believe so no I don't think so bad
it's such this is those bomb pop that's
like yeah it's like that's not good
humor
by the way the company is called
popsicle yeah
holy [__] by the way you know what this
is a this is a dude this is a
neighborhood we've never even been in
popsicles yeah yeah it's a good thing
like ice cream truck [__]
Summer's around the corner can I tell
you something right now pop look at that
bomb pop I don't know chocolate banana
pass oh that's what that is oh that I'm
less excited can I tell you somewhere
now are these rocket pops still a thing
to today's generation I mean they're
still out you can still find them in any
Supermarket you [__] somebody you [__]
with rainbow pops Bomb Pops
you do you've eaten them yeah okay the
red white and blue so there's still a
thing okay pimp just type in Good Humor
ice cream bars I want to see like all
the different what's your take on the
merino's Italian ice we gotta get this
is all battles we've never been in yes
done before Summer's around the corner
right there somewhere no no click on the
the second picture pip wait no no pimp
stop right there
sorry
now I love so this is
this is wait a minute
popsicles
making the chocolate eclair and
strawberry bars well that's that's crazy
wait maybe Good Humor didn't make them
they did I think it's uh depending upon
whoever they're buying from distributor
yeah I don't think they have a lock on
it I'm going to tell you this you want
to talk about holy [__] popsicle brand
they got creamsicles they got the fudge
everyone has creamsicles though so
here's the thing but you you're talking
about Isis as far as Rocket pops Isis
what do you want to bring terrorism into
this yeah I I the creamsicle pop is the
best ice pop
hands down my least favorite popsicle
ice cream treat of all time creamsicle
yes you're a weird person I think it's
disgusting I think it's okay put
creamsicle down because that's a battle
oh yeah it sucks
while you're at it you [__] pig don't
don't talk to me like that what's your
take on the merino's Italian ice who
doesn't love a merino's okay so because
this is something we we this is and I'll
say this I'll say this ready I'll go on
record saying this and I'm speaking I'm
speaking against my hometown when I say
this
in that hard Marina little Merino with
the heart with the little wood spoon
sometimes the spoon splinters because
it's so hard yeah yeah and you know you
wait and you flip it over and it's
crystallizations on the other side and
then at the end you mix it you drink the
last bit of it and you know what though
that's another point where you can
finally flip when the finally flip hits
you're like this is come on we're busy
I'll tell you nothing I think they did
away with the wax cups but just like
that though I don't like the plastic do
you know what I had at marinos there was
Tuesday nights at my bar was merino's
Italian ice tonight so if you ordered a
drink at my bar on Tuesday nights if you
so choose in the summer you can you get
a free merino's Italian that's fun now
here's the other thing we had merino's
Italian ice shots the menu of them and I
would make the shots red blue and lemon
the three biggest flavors I would make
shots of those and they tasted
identical to the merinos so people used
to order a shot get the free merinos
open it and then pour the shot into it
mix up and have a spiked Merino ice this
sort of thing I did this is 20 years ago
I was I was really trailblazing this
stuff
um talk to me about it we do a fun thing
with the coffee place next door that's
the black cat oh do you really yeah
we'll we'll do we'll do specials where
we say go buy a coffee but I can't bring
it over there so five bucks we'll spike
it oh that's so fun it's fun right yeah
that's fun doing stuff like that do they
know that black cat yeah yeah they
advertise it oh they do they'll say like
you can go next door and get a spike in
here okay but what do they do for you oh
they advertise it there okay got it got
it got it you know looking for the
negative I mean you know no no because
you you said I just I'm not looking for
negative all right uh what about okay oh
yeah we're doing we're an almost yeah
um what about a push pop what about it
the orange sherbet push pop that we used
to have like the uh I love a push-up
colorful I like circles and you like
yeah like a plastic like kind of I love
a push pop yeah yeah yeah push-pumps on
to cook it over which spots like the
Capri Sun of popsicles like if there's a
device involved yeah it's kind of
different in fun yeah all right so we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna go like
whoa uh in in these summer months with
this stuff we're gonna go wild I mean
Carvel into the mix now
soft serve I love come on but these are
these are Pips there we are for a second
you know we should do this this here the
month of July thing like the month of
like June or July we should do look
where I'm pointing
I'm pointing at the SpongeBob pop right
you see this is all new school I do it's
not frog
all right yeah but hear me out fat frog
okay
I didn't make it anymore
I'm pointing at the SpongeBob for a
reason that's it that style of ice cream
pop to me is the king yeah that's the
king the Frog was great they did a Super
Mario one at one point yeah
those that style of ice cream pop you
could only get it to this truck yeah you
still can't buy those things by the box
I don't think in a store yeah I I think
fat can you write uh type in fat frog
that was besides the chip witch and the
my three big ones were the chip which
the push pop and the fat one right there
good humor forever now can we still get
that right now because and by the way it
was Vanilla
no but it was dyed light green no it
tasted limey no no you're you're off
you're did I like I like the ones that
are the fruity flavors and the back of
the fat frog had a coating and dipped in
chocolate Okay m m eyes or chocolate the
Pac-Man one because it tasted almost
like lemony yes I liked I liked the ones
that had like a fruitish food do you
remember like the one like ice age or
whatever where like it was like the you
know the Push Pops that are in like the
longer ones that one was great but the
glove with the baseball bubble gum yep
that was do you remember the one do you
remember the one that was like it was
like a glacier pop or whatever and it
looked like a Iceberg and then in the
middle of it was a frozen dinosaur candy
no they really found a way to to uh
blown Extinction fat frog says request
this item I feel like it's it's gone
uh vintage ice pops click bubble they
say and request it so they could see
what people are asking for these days
requests to come back you can vote to
bring back oh guys go on to
goodhumor.com and do me a favor do Sal a
favor here request a fat frog to come
and the baseball glove come on give me a
baseball glove too
they're not going to be allowed to call
it fat frog if they bring it back there
why because fat shaming you have to call
it
a husky frog you know uh uh body
positivity frog
more to love frog yeah hummus okay oh no
wait we have to start okay start it
official all right sorry that's all
right
if you want to do them no matter what
happens we haven't done one yeah ready
yeah we didn't yeah okay all right
no matter what happens I love you
love you d-l-e budge and shout out to
the couple that came into Joey roses and
told me I videotaped it and sent it to
Sal they are closing their wedding vows
with no matter what happens I love you
we love you guys with the chant with the
chance they did it on video in the bar
and I said it to Sal and they were like
we're doing it in our vows we're
influencing podcasts
yeah it was crazy the guy for our new
fans of the fans have been with us for
day one
we I just thank you to you guys thank
you it's fun this is an interactive
podcast it's silly podcast it's it's we
have so much fun and we appreciate you
guys we appreciate you guys leave us a
rating on iTunes please leave a rating
on it yeah that you want to never say
that but it's a good rating we love you
if you wanna if you want to help us if
you want to help us at all take one
minute and leave us a rating on iTunes
follow us on YouTube at the no pressure
Network subscribe subscribe subscribe
like subscribe to hit that like do all
the stuff right but subscribe on YouTube
and rate US on iTunes that's big do us a
favor you haven't done it yet what are
you waiting for we give you we give and
we give and this is where it goes off
the rails don't don't I just want to
know
uh I am team hummus now I gotta tell you
there was a time
where if you told me I had to not be
team onion dip I would have fought you
I love onion dip I've always loved onion
dip to me it's the only dip for potato
chips period the only flavors for potato
chip outside of plain for me are salt
and vinegar or sour cream and onion and
sour cream and onion depending on the
brand can I just say one thing not to
even Sidetrack but just add you should
now try pickle chips in that rotation oh
I love pickle chips sorry I forgot about
pickle chips
um but pickle chips versus uh for pickle
chips versus uh salt and vinegar chips
that might be a nice battle no because
both of our favorites are sour cream or
strawberry do pickle versus sour cream
and onion sour cream is a Titan
well
pickle chips versus barbecue chips
sour cream and onion versus barbecue
okay great I love it let me write that
down
uh all right so anyway
um yes there was a time where I would
have fought you to not defend onion dip
but I gotta say
hummus
has become a part of my daily life
daily life I eat hummus every single day
uh carrots or cucumbers and or cucumbers
dipped into hummus has become my only
snack
uh it's the only thing I will eat
between meals it's the one thing I'll
eat
sometimes if I'm really really hungry
and I'm cooking I eat it while I'm
cooking a little bit as an app
um it's healthy it's so good for you
I mean it's it's I shouldn't say it's so
good for you it's it's a legume at the
end of the day legumes can add belly fat
but there's a lot of tremendous fiber
and hummus hummus absolutely has Health
qualities and and positives to it that
onion dip just does not uh
um and and hummus
you know I'll start by saying hummus
aside from playing a part in my daily
life which onion dip could not in any
sane diet uh I would say that hummus
also is of the two could be a meal it's
a meal dip it's a meal dip onion dip is
not a meal dip there's no such term as a
meal dip dip in and of itself is an ox
meal dip is an oxymoron you could have
hummus with vegetables as a meal you
could not have chips vegetables is the
star of the show there but I'm saying
the hummus is the accoutrement of course
but I'm saying you couldn't have chips
and and onion dip as a meal and feel
anyway but you're just attaching chips
to onion dip you could have a carrot and
celery with an onion dip I don't think
you could have vegetables with onion dip
no and onion
I'm saying you could do it I'm saying
you are not gonna feel good afterwards
and and nobody would do it you feel good
after having hummus yes you're feeling
different you don't feel good you know
like loaded up on hummus I'll tell you
let me go out and conquer them I have
never seen on a menu in a restaurant
accoutrement of vegetables with onion
dip I've never seen that ever I've seen
hummus infections in a crudite a lot of
times excuse me oh they they do Ranch
and ranch I make an argument Sal
if you are going to sit here right now
because I think you're about to do this
okay I think you're about to do this
okay you're all sacked today are you
gonna tell me that you've seen
vegetables in ranch dip on a menu is
that what you're about to say no no no
okay every single night that I'm on the
road and the rider is fruit and a crew
today right and every time they bring me
a crudite which is celery sometimes
broccoli usually carrots yes the center
thing that comes in yeah always has
Ranch I don't open it because I don't
like dipping stuff in ranch not not if
you were arguing Ranch this would be
valuable information but my point is is
that like it's not onion dip is my point
right Ranch is a salad dressing right
there it's right there it's no that's
[__] you can't make that argument
you just said that you wouldn't picture
dipping veggies okay then I'll then I'll
go with you there on Ranch even you
wouldn't see no you can dip vegetables
in onion dip I've done it I do it I've
done it at parties what I'm saying to
you is you could take hummus and
vegetables and actually have a balanced
decent meal you cannot take onion dip
and vegetables and go that was a decent
meal I just had okay well let me just
say you're going to say I ruined a
healthy thing with onion dip that is
I'm sure it does I mean we argue
Ice Cream versus this candy for a second
nobody's not saying where's the most
healthy nobody's eating either of these
things with a spoon
spoons healthy
that's definitely part of it thank you
pimp yes say it into the mic why don't
you say the negatives into the mic but
say the positives into the mic this
[__] guy today the health is not a
part of it we argue the healthy aspects
of every food we talk about let's go
back to taste because taste is where I'm
gonna beat you okay let's go because
hummus tastes like okay here's the thing
wondrous beautiful beans
okay fabric life folks let's talk about
fabric light insurance as the weather
warms up and flowers start to bloom it's
a perfect time to take a fresh look at
your financial planning uh if you've
been meaning to get life insurance maybe
you've been putting it off a bit I know
I have I have I had a cold this week
about life insurance which I do not have
which is pretty much insane for someone
uh my age with fabric by Gerber Life
it's quick and easy to help protect your
family's future so you can get back to
enjoying life as a parent your top
priority is always going to be your
children's well-being you want to give
them everything they need to grow and
Thrive both now and in the future with
term life insurance from fabric by
Gerber Life help protect your family so
their future is secure was designed by
parents for parents to help you get a
high quality surprisingly affordable
term life insurance policy in less than
10 minutes I know some of you are saying
but Joe you're not a parent why are you
selling me this well I know a lot of
parents and I know a lot of people that
need this and could use this and I also
know that life insurance is not the kind
of thing you want to wake up and go oh
crap I should have done that yesterday
I like knowing about this project
intimidating life insurance and get a
bad rap of being complicated I will tell
you this is an online Hub that is a
seamless digital experience it takes
less than 10 minutes and you see your
quote you can personalize your quote to
fit your family's needs you could be
offered coverage in coverage instantly
no Health exam required no Health exam
required that's amazing it's a 30-day
money-back guarantee you cancel any time
there's nothing to lose here okay
protect your family today with fabric by
Gerber Life apply today in just 10
minutes at meetfabric.com
tastebuds that's meat m-e-e-t fabric.com
slash tastebuds m-e-e-t fabric.com
policies issued by Western Southern life
insurance company not available in
certain States price is subject to
underwriting and health questions
hummus tastes like okay here's the thing
wondrous beautiful
creamy beans hummus right hummus came
into my life maybe like 10 years ago and
hummus for me is Hit or Miss but wildly
Hit or Miss okay sometimes hummus
because shout out to Sabra apply this to
Hummus is the one of the most why can't
I speak I'm sorry I'm sorry that's okay
the red lid yeah I only notice the red
lid because let's be honest they've got
it cornered they I think they have a
corner because there's another brand
with like a green lid I'm not naming
names but I don't think it Compares so
Sabra I love because they are very
innovative
and they'll have like uh you know pine
nuts and garlic they'll have red pepper
in there and you mix it up and
I think why Sabra is so good is they
found the key to Hummus which is yes
they do sell a plain hummus but then
they have 30 other skus
that are flavored hummuses and I think
you need a little something in with the
flavor of regular hummus to put it over
the top for me can I tell you if I'm
having a regular straightforward hummus
it is a shot in the dark at whether that
hummus tastes palatable or tastes like
throw up can I oh stop it
stop it bad hummus tastes like passable
throw up oh stop it I'm not joking
around it feels like it feels like
regurgitation
that is just okay enough to swallow let
me say that I promise let me say this
and I will say this too sometimes hummus
smells
really bad oh you're so funny sometimes
hummus smells like body odor or
something oh stop it Sal it never was
like beer
it does
it has a very weird you have a weird
smell smell I don't I shower twice a day
I I'm gonna say this and I say it
without exaggeration and you're not
gonna believe me and I promise you it's
true I have never had a flavored hummus
I have only ever bought and consumed you
want to play that game bro you want to
play that I have always fly in seconds I
buy a thing of the promise every week
and I show you can I show you what I did
at the supermarket last week we gotta
show you what I did the super working
last week I went shopping for the week
it was Sunday actually it was Sunday I
went shopping for the week I was in line
it was empty the store is pretty empty I
said to the lady but it was crowded
enough that I had to move fast I hope
these details the hummus
yeah
Mrs near like to the registers because
it's in the produce section the I said
to the to check out lady I go [__] I
forgot to get hummus she goes go ahead
just run and get it I go thank you there
was one guy behind me I had to be fast I
ran to the hummus section I got there
red lid went right for red lid
they were out of the plane out loud in
the supermarket I go come on like that
and grabbed a different brand because
the other brand had plane and that one
didn't you why why in the world as a
hummus lover wouldn't you be your
interests be peaked because you want to
try one of the things I love so much
about hummus is I love two things about
hummus I find it to be delicious
and I find it to be nutritious you can
say that and I and I'm serious though
that is what I love about it and it's
it's it's it's I don't want to add stuff
to it that could that could mess with
that flavor number one
number two take away from the
nutritional value because now I'm adding
extra oil or I'm adding extra sodium or
adding extra whatever because there's
olives in it now or whatever it is I
like I like my hummus plane I dip
oh so you flavor it yourself and that's
what you're saying you flavor it
yourself no I dip things in it like all
of sane rational America what about the
things you're dipping in it are things
that they use to flavor it as well right
so you're telling me that you carrots
you're telling me carrots you use the
flavor you're telling me that you love
some of the things right peppers they do
right I don't get peppers in it oh
pepperoncini sorry sorry I thought you
meant um I think you meant for some
reason I thought you meant red pepper
sorry no so so so you're telling me Oh
by the way I dipped two pepperoncini and
I'm not eating a whole jar of pepper and
cheese all right so you dip two in yeah
all right I don't want it in every bite
okay yeah here's the deal you love how
much that much yet you bulk at the
chance to try 20 interesting different
flavors like what I like okay fine I
will tell you this if you're going
against me with plain hummus only
then we should I'll go flavors we should
have noted that because plain hummus
alone
stuff buddy I'll go get you with the
flavors too I love that there's a huge
selection I just don't partake have you
ever had the snack box on a United
flight yes and they come with a little
hummus that hummus and I don't mean to
put anybody out of work
that hummus that hummus literally is one
of the worst tasting things I have ever
tasted like because I don't mind how
much this is
how much you have to go how much is who
the the the the hummus at thirty
thousand feet it's going between
Poughkeepsie and St Louis it's also
going between L.A and Tokyo bro okay
really it doesn't taste good it's a
major brand that got an account that is
huge your hummus doesn't taste good air
hummus crazy dude you know what I also
find that the cuts of cheese aren't
coming if I go to like a beautiful
Mediterranean restaurant I order a
hummus and they make it fresh delightful
but I'm telling you right now that a
straightforward hummus is hit or miss a
hundred percent of time I don't know
what I'm gonna get and I I opened that
hummus and I had crackers with it and I
literally it literally tasted like vomit
I'm telling you if I close my eyes and
ate that I'd be like you got someone
vomited yeah they mix you got a bad
hummus one time
every time well then stop getting the
air hummus it comes with other things
stop getting the airplane on this hummus
is the food paste of the Gods onion
Dippers for the divorced
here's the thing here's the thing okay I
don't know
I know way less people if any at all
that I hear go onion dip no
joke hold on we got great comments on
the phones
onion different parties Dermatology talk
the whole time and wait my turn Okay
read this read that word which one onion
dip reminds me onion dip reminds me of
parties during my childhood me too
hummus reminds me of
all right do you see why I got this
that was good that is good all right God
sorry it does remind me of it reminds me
of parties it reminds you of absolutely
and and pretzels are out onion dip or
vegetables but here's the thing I don't
really recall anyone going oh God onion
dip like I think even if people like are
like fine with onion dip no one's like
onion dip is gross I promise you that
hummus is a polarizing
um
did you ever smell you tell me that
you've never smelled a hummus and said
this smells like a Bo vomit combination
no no and you want to talk about Hit or
Miss brother I I wish I had hummus with
me right now I wish I had a girlfriend
of onion dip one and it's the onion dip
that's a little bit tan French onion dip
if you will because they use they use a
little bit of the beef whatever whatever
right
you just said that there's only one
onion dip that's good right that's what
you said I'm telling you okay there's
only one onion you have the most white
onion dips
are way too sour cream heavy that's why
they're bright white they don't have
enough sour cream they don't have enough
of the other flavors
when I dunk a chip into a an onion dip
and I bite it and I get predominantly
sour cream over the seasoning flavor it
makes me want to puke dude I feel like I
put a glob of milk
yes it happens a lot I'll tell you I'll
tell you the onion dip I hate I'll tell
you the brand I hate I won't even buy it
because I do buy onion dip Trader Joe's
is a wonderful onion dip by the way TJ's
knows what they're doing all right
however hell of a brand onion dip sucks
what nothing he's putting people out of
work here
it tastes just like sour cream I I love
salad you know what I like if you like
the little Frito-Lay one that weirdly
doesn't need to be refrigerated I don't
understand
after opening a test after opening yeah
but buying that on the aisle baby you
you know that how much is a polarizing
uh food right I don't think that it is
you don't think you've never taken a
bite of hummus no but carrots how many
times I have to say no but I didn't
finish the question you've asked me this
question three times what's the question
and and it's good and it tastes like Bo
in your mouth or vomit yeah I know what
you're gonna say no it just never
happened you're wild if you tell me that
you've never both smelled and tasted oh
hummus wherever it came from that tastes
like
manageable throw did you see vanitya's
face when you made that compassion she
was like what the [__] she was talking
she was born into a vat of hummus it
doesn't count
she's got she has hummus perfume it
doesn't count no but all right but no no
not for nothing you could be honest
you've had a billion things hummus and I
don't know if you're so in tune with
that as a native taste to you that you
can't distinguish a bad husband no
matter what though this bad and good of
things does anyone know what I mean even
when I tell you that some hummus tastes
like a Bo vomit and also it smells like
it yeah the v v
[Laughter]
in Louisiana
is there a suggestion box a comment card
for this podcast because I want to leave
an anonymous comment for the podcast on
a global scale onion dipped is enjoyed
on a trailer park scale you can't be
crave dude I I I I don't agree with that
onion if onion dip is is a heartbeat of
America it's at every single children's
party it's at everything
it's at every party when chips and dips
are put out nobody opposes onion dip
everyone loves onion dip so these people
that are hating on any dip they only
hating on themselves we're at we're at
the end anyway we got to go to the
phones here are we yeah yeah where we at
yeah we're at like 54 minutes oh okay
hummus is the dip that you bring home to
meet your parents onion dip is the one
you sneak in through the back door my
niece will eat a thing of onion dip
straight out of the container must be
the tick tock children
hummus is for the refined palette it's
way more versatile onion dip is only for
chips and veggies
uh you want to read some of these please
uh can't beat the vast variety of
flavors of hummus well Joe doesn't like
it
onion dip is only good at a retirement
party not not true but that's also where
it is I wonder why why it is that you
can find onion dip at every single party
all right if it's terrible why is it at
every party you you
staple at parties are things that bring
parties to life it's not at every party
I think that is a very East Coast thing
I have not I I lived an onion dip across
the world I lived in L.A for six years I
never saw any dip once at a party out
there you're gonna find hummus you
aren't going to party tonight there's a
reason why man nobody's inviting you to
put the [__] parties how am I gonna
die in your parties
what is your gonna get personal all
right I knew I knew a few people all
right hummus equals healthier onion dip
equals taste I mean nothing too you
don't have that hummus within the first
couple hour or so oh it's even it's
taking it yeah cause the onion dip warms
nicely out on the table that's great as
it gets hotter I'm telling you though
bad hummus old hummus homemade varieties
is this hummus homemade varieties will
generate less anywhere from three to
four days whereas store-bought Brands
last six to seven days after opening not
out not non-refrigerated though yeah of
course you have to refrigerate it so the
same thing with onion dip
onion dip Frito-Lay says that once open
its French onion dip is good for 10 to
14 days homemade versions four to seven
that is a dairy-based product that is
lasting 10 to 14 days all right pimp we
got to go we got to go to the vote here
Humble Pie segment let's give the win to
the 911 person
that made us last we laugh really hard
we got how many votes here all right
seven thousand yeah ready
God damn it
oh what yes what oh god thank you God
Jesus Lord thank you Jesus Lord what
there's no way and now Sal reviewed the
record right does that put him behind
you wait wait wait wait wait that's yeah
yeah yeah well oh wait oh wait no no so
so no so wait the record for the show
I thought hold on I got sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry it's okay but how do you feel
I was on the no-pressnetwork.com today
which is a lovely site that'll give you
both podcasts all of our merch all of
our live touring it gives everything
good job on that it's great it's a Well
Done website it's up to date all the
time it has every battle all of our
records season one I outpaced Joe by
five wins season two I outpaced Joe by
five wins we are in season three and it
is a dead Heat
[Laughter]
right now you look like ditch Joe
it looks like just wrap it up give me
the lines oh sorry you sound like sour
like the hummus It's The End
we didn't even say humble pie seg yeah
we should we didn't say what it was you
said the percentages 54 but that's close
I gotta be honest I didn't think I was
gonna win and I didn't think I was gonna
win especially after going to the phones
54.8 onion dip 45.2 how much that's
within five points that means it's an
automatic
um rematch candidate but onion dip takes
the win over hummus despite points it's
ten what are you talking about within a
five point swing
no if it was like if it was almost
53-47 this is a 10 point difference if I
must got five points added to it it'll
be winning
is what I mean no it wouldn't sure it'll
be 50.1
to
44 okay
great great
all right
go ahead
well I thought I was going to lose after
going to the phones I really did but I
do think that onion dip is more
universally like I do think hummus is
polarizing I can't believe it how we end
this show
21 episodes you do the number and you
say I still love you I go I love you
that's the end we could do that but
sometimes I have well we have a guess
giving this episode out there for 20
minutes
I told you quarter of it's 302. you
didn't tell me they arrived you told me
that their intention of the time they're
gonna arrive Joe
you have a sour attitude today and we
did it no matter what happens I love you
there was two I let you speak every time
it was two times that I started to speak
you disregarded what I was saying and
all you did was go to the phones we all
saw it now I'm trying to say something
and you won't even let me say something
trying to keep us on track here because
there's a format to the show I don't
know about your attitude that we do that
is so you're not a sure winner that you
take the win and you say I still love it
I was just kidding I'm just kidding the
point a million times we get it all your
[__] parties have onion dip everybody
loves onions Bo tastes like hummus we've
we've said it a hundred times we
understand the points you said
everything 100 times too no I didn't
actually you did you you were you were
busy reading other people's comments and
laughing just because you're
steamrolling doesn't mean that uh you're
right or you're gonna win an episode as
we see evident here today you steamroll
me through the whole thing and you took
a big fat l I still love you taste buds
they come into the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two Fool's gonna fight but
only one food can be right taste buds